it's already looking like it's going to
be a strong opening weekend for Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker but the film's violent
nature is also sparking major security
concerns nationwide is it just a game
changer out there
the film has Phoenix playing a failed
comedian who goes on a killing spree
and now after online threats were posted
on social media the FBI is urging local
law enforcement to be on alert expect
beefed up security at theaters many of
which are banning costumes what's so
funny I thought that it was gonna be
challenging for me as an actor I was
gonna be challenging for the audience
playing the creepy clown is something
that Joaquin actually embraced from the
beginning starting with losing 52 pounds
it was something that I've done before
and I swore when I did before that I'd
never do it again
but it seemed like it was really
important for the character and I think
it may end up affecting me in ways that
that I hadn't anticipated and certainly
it affects your emotional mental state
as for that laugh we've heard that from
every Joker on screen
[Music]
but at some point it would become easier
but I don't think it did it may became
more difficult actually
you don't listen to you are you having
any negative thoughts all I have my
negative thoughts you feel like you
would would want to play Joker again
[Music]
[Applause]